like let's say I'm an artist I got a
Pepsi commercial yeah make me as sexy as
possible while I sit this what should I
do pretend that's a penis he already did
[Laughter]
and that's a vagina however you want it
well that's what Pepsi would want though
right they want like that sexual
innuendo in their commercial right just
lick the rim no that's cool that's
McDonald's
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boy
today we have Steve's worst nightmare a
room full of dancers
art by the way why was that Steve's
worst nightmare
um insecurity oh okay
usually the word most things like that
start right yeah yeah Steve's kind of
like a [ __ ] you know so we haven't had
Ellen here in what like nine years you
said yeah
you said you saw an old episode of her
here I wanted to check I was like yo we
should have Ellen on here so it's like
has she been on I looked it up why I
thought you met Ellen DeGeneres I
saw the oldest 240p video and I was like
that's the last time she was here
technology was this dang back during
Jurassic Park yeah but yeah now we have
her back Ellen Kim is back everybody
for having me yeah thank you for coming
laugh the whole time that's good that's
a good thing also we have Chris Sosa
over there
and we have that Kristen Farina
she's a dancer
you're a dancer
see I I I'm telling you guys can just
learn from me I could believe yeah I'm
barked like you did yeah but it looks
like
I don't know
oh
it started
hey do you watch out just white face
you're gonna get a a nice little call in
a few minutes
almost a decade ago 240p oh yeah that
was 240p to go I think um you were you
were still a choreographer back then but
now you've branched off into a lot of
other different facets of you know
things you can do as a dancer she's a
really good example of like higher
places you can get to I think what's the
next level okay are really nice I need
to like hang out with you all the time
because he's always saying good things
about me dude where are you getting this
I have a question okay so uh if you're
if you're a dancer
and you're dancing here we go right this
is you're dancing and you're making
money Dancing Yeah and then the next
stage what is it that's there you go so
what is the yeah the next stage that's a
lot of people have that you go do I do
comedy do I do DJ or do you do what what
what's the actual dance progression I
would say like creative director no
don't look at me no no this is your
moment
I don't want to ask Anthony I don't want
to ask Anthony for me my career started
going down so I went to JK news
this is the place to live
well I think being a dancer like I don't
know you're so in tune with your
emotions and your creativity and your
thoughts and all this stuff so I feel
like to be a DJ you understand music
very well and so DJing is really easy
yeah like an easy music creative
Direction so like right now I'm doing
creative direction for a tech company
what's creative Direction that's crazy
um like basically what I do is like
listen to everyone tell me what the like
what they want yeah and then I go
delegate the work because and I put it
together and I go okay how does this all
work and blend together in the visuals
and marketing The Branding and how do I
get these folks and my resources and I
bring them together to do it for like an
ad or like a marketing campaign
marketing ads campaign now I work in
like right next to with us this is so
boring but like with it
but I work with like HR because now I'm
doing like social impact work for the
company now working on like uh in blah
blah blah no yeah okay that wasn't even
one
I wanted to give a whole thought yet
basically it's like
yo you matter yo I matter no I'm curious
I'm curious it's not letting you say it
you know what because because like
everyone's watching they're probably
like I'm gonna be a dancer one day but
then but then there's life after what's
the next day like I said JLo do you
become a jail what do you become it
depends what do you want it's like the
question is do you want to be famous do
you want to like for me I want to impact
people I want to create communities and
I want to be around folks and do good
work so that's why I went into more of a
social impact and creative direction for
a tech company and I want to bring that
back to the dance world because you can
go into business being a dancer right
you can
he's a noodle salesman I'm also a shoe
cobbler apparently I think that's a it's
a really common question I think because
some people especially if you're wanting
to get into dance and you've been told
that like oh well then it's too late or
you can only do it for a while and then
you have to stop it's not necessarily
that but whatever skill that you harness
and you develop during that time can be
repurposed to something bigger always
absolutely that's what I was gonna say
is like um not that dancers are Elite or
anything but the skills we do learn with
dancing whether it's like working with
people you know if you're in a group
dancing with people you have to learn
how to communicate and work with people
movement you were saying there are so
many people that have no clue how to
even move not dance but like people need
movement coaches so you could work with
the artist and just teach them how to
just like naturally go with the flow or
you can go to the choreographing
directing that side of things so it
really can take you anywhere that's so
true so that like I started movement
coaching and then now started teaching
kids and use the same I like ideas and
um
program into kids and I want to build a
kids program for education for public
schools and that's where my mind is at
like from oh that's cool leveling up the
Next Generation because this one that's
coming up is that there's this kind of
they're lost we threw that one away
tried but like the next one the next one
they got it gen Z we failed
we gotta take the L and move on
what's the next one called so as an
example of movement coaching like let's
say I'm an artist I got a Pepsi
commercial make me as sexy as possible
while I sit this what should I do
pretend that's a penis
[Laughter]
that's what Pepsi would want though
right they want like that sexual
innuendo in their commercial right just
lick the Rim Yeah
is that like that's McDonald's
especially your dad's career you end up
also developing leadership qualities
yeah leadership qualities is exactly
what makes you level up I think level up
level up level up you're not going to be
in charge of a whole project what's cool
about being creative director that she
was saying is that even though it sounds
like she's gonna get all the glory for
all these delegated positions she's also
the person that's going to be blamed if
anyone's people [ __ ] up so it's
actually a lot heavier than it sounds
it's not as easy as it might appear any
director role though
man you're just a [ __ ] it's always
your fault
they're producer
set design
of director yeah it's more like that I
know yeah yeah do you see that the
Simpsons though uh
they uh foreshadowed what it was Oh What
The Simpsons had another Balenciaga
prediction yeah for Balenciaga
specifically there were like the kids
were walking in The Simpsons and they're
like they literally say Balenciaga and
like um I think Bart spent over not not
this part but other Bart but here but
here's my thing with with the Simpsons
when they when they show the the
prediction part right yeah
um do people remember watching that
episode are they just making are they
just making them now that has happened
before where people thought that
Simpsons predicted it but actually it
was this way yeah
they might have predicted one or two and
then they just like let's keep this
running then that apparently happens
with everything from SNL to anything
that is parodying the real life
eventually something will hit because
it's making fun of actual [ __ ] that does
happen it is great marketing though
because that is a thing everybody knows
Simpson's predictions as a concept right
that is like an actual when's the last
time you guys watched the full Simpsons
I don't even watch I don't know I feel
like it's so different now though it is
what attention span is pretty short all
right I just want it perfect for a
creative director
who are you
so when didn't you work with the um was
it K Dog how do you say it the freaking
KDA League of Legends yeah how was that
what did you do fun
um because that's [ __ ] message
that's huge I love it though uh
do you love them yeah I actually really
like their music KDA is really cool
because uh they were like one of the
first uh like virtual pop groups so
they're not like technically human
beings they're like characters from The
League of Legend game but it's done well
the IP put it together grab some like
ghost voices and Ghost Riders put the
whole thing together Ellen was
choreographing from a couple people that
uh on our team with choreographed for
them and was just kind of more I think
the novelty of like creating a virtual
pop group and then having it be like
successful in its own right I think
that's more of like a
just like the interesting part of like
where we're at in technology where we're
at in like pop culture and music and
stuff like that it was super Innovative
and fun and they're all like you know
they're kind of hot you know what I'm
saying you know for these like fine ass
three-dimensional characters is that
like the gorillas where they're just
breaking music but you know no no let's
let's sit on this Anthony you you got
something for
uh they're kind of hot let's expand on
that I know sometimes I wish I was a
cartoon because I just want to make love
to cartoons which one well here's the
thing so I did like a 2d project before
and there are just like do dance moves
and I was like where are they gonna put
this and it's in a 2d life where you can
purchase these moves and go to clubs and
so people get married now and hang out
in 2D world so if you go ahead and do
that actually wow I wonder if it'll be
considered cheating it depends on what
your Arrangement is I guess remember
that Black Mirror episode when the guys
were playing games so oh that's not
cheating that's not cheating and they
started having sex
they were like best friends and then
they had mad sex yeah I remember that
remember that they're like Street
Fighter and then they're like having mad
sexual experiences the crazy thing too
is like it is like gorillas but the
crazier thing is that if gorillas was
from another game first that's what
trips me out it's like KDA we're
characters from League of Legends yeah
yeah League of Legends Oh wow was that
when I worked there they were having a
whole issue in the company it was a
scandal whoa was an issue of like how
the workers were being treated the
female workers would I do make make them
game too much that's a game company at
the game yeah yeah right right that was
huge that was interesting because I
actually got to see I saw it happening
yeah you saw the girls get harassed in
front of you they just got treated kind
of messed up did they get like talked
down to and [ __ ] yeah so I was like oh
this is a really interesting was it the
Asian company side
oh yeah see has that ever happened to
you yet as a yet that's kind of [ __ ]
up as a creative director always anyone
ever been like really they're like shut
up girl you don't know nothing time even
choreography world like
when I started this it was mostly guys
guys like Anthony yeah yeah there's one
time don't put me there
you don't [ __ ] do that right
you're more success
you're leading you you [ __ ] like that
you're a choreographing a lot
your sad fees at some point I [ __ ]
know your ass I'm outside the community
you [ __ ] graper I like that
just accuse each other being more
successful
throwing me under the bus like the [ __ ]
accused women of [ __ ] this [ __ ]
um what do I look like Bart
you're playing Bart edit that in so
that's that's happened to you recently
even
or is that like an old thing because
creative director you think is that
that's a higher position than quarters
are we talking about sexual harassment
are we talking about they're not
listening to because they're like you're
a girl that's like the disparity between
how you would treat like a male creative
director versus female like is there a
mansplaining a lot yeah and that in the
tech world just huge too so because
nerds don't know how to talk to girls
yeah you think that's really wise huh
because
I kind of felt like that was it but I
didn't know if that was mean I thought
just nerds don't know how to talk to
people in general so they're just being
[ __ ] socially stupid no matter who
they speak to they're a little bit
Shapiro is Sean
all stats
there's no breaks in their [ __ ]
sentences Doug they don't take no breath
like cold and logical yeah but it's like
they don't listen to people and [ __ ] but
it's not like what you would think where
like they're not smacking asses and
going get me a love tea yeah make me a
sandwich woman yeah and then where's
that company I've never no it's a it's
an old oil tycoon are you allowed to say
what a tech company you work at oh I
work for a premium blend and that's not
like mansplaining that's not there but
working with other ones I I realize it's
no different from like production work
it's all the same just out of curiosity
how did that uh opportunity like come up
for you
to become a creative director at like a
tech company especially coming from like
a dancer's background they need brand
they need new eyes on branding so
they're just like I don't want to go
traditional I want to try this out and I
was like okay they sought you out
um and they hit you up and that's
amazing because this the one of the
person's already he's a singer as well
so that's how we met is through his work
for Creative direction for his uh
also has a company so he's like I like
the way you creative direct here I want
to see how we can do it in the like a
text that's amazing it's really fun I
thought the tech company was just trying
to be different and they're like let's
hire a dancer yeah
we need a woman we need a minority and
we need to like get this how crazy would
it be we get Ellen Kim a [ __ ] dancer
and when you show up they're like how
come you're not in Cosplay
one thing I I have witnessed is that
sometimes when it comes to like creative
Direction and choreography you'll have
two people in those positions and then
somewhere down the line as the project
goes the choreographer will know more
about what the [ __ ] to do than the
director always that person is destined
to become this person you ever seen that
happen a thousand percent you're on set
and you're like wait you're supposed to
know why do you know and how come you're
killing it today and they're not and
then like next time you see them oh
you're the director now holy [ __ ] like
I've seen that they get fired well they
just move up because somebody the right
person noticed that this person was
going Beyond and this person was not
being lazy yeah yeah and a lot of
choreographers have that mind to be the
director anyway but they're just not
that position yeah a lot of great
choreographers not about the [ __ ]
combos of moves they put together yeah
how do you fire or bad dancer how do you
fire him yeah when they're on stage
you're just like that once yeah sucks
no no you just don't get hired but what
if they're there what if they slip
through the crack you get fired on set
I've been fired from a tour
um and it was why didn't Usher not like
you oh sure it was because at that time
they straight up told me I was too fat
[Music]
I've kept that with me forever geez and
I I don't want to have to talk about the
choreographer or even the artist because
you know well if you want to you could
just lay it all out
uh one day I think I will
their name rhymes with
butter
Reagan Crainer
but here's the thing that's like [ __ ]
up about it like I had to call some
friends because you know
when you are let go because of your
looks right after you work so hard to
learn whatever I'm not gonna get into it
I call like my friends in in the
industry yeah and of course I knew what
I was gonna get back but they're like
well girl you know you can't be fat I'm
like that was their response yeah holy
[ __ ] but I was like you're right and
then I went to like major depression
I like how we cut out the [ __ ] in
between you're going straight to the
depression it's real though it was real
depression it can't be back and the body
shaping crazy with girl dancers we go to
I mean I don't really audition anymore
but like if you go to an audition they
will type cast I've had one time they
had all the girls get in the line and
turn around and they literally just
looked at our butts and then they were
like thank you for coming I was like
today they're like nobody here has an
ass it's like a real it's a real she's
like it was a Fruit of the Loom
commercial so I don't get it okay
it just reminds me of the uh the scene
from Bring It On you see from Bring It
On where he's like smile don't smile and
then he like leans over and looks at the
bus and also like the the choreographer
the the one they hired for the chill I'm
the only one that watch Bring it on here
everybody
yeah they're not you're the only true
dancer here they're good I've been told
I was too dark for uh this one
commercial and I didn't get it and I
watched it and it was a black dude who
got it
you have a dark personality
I'm too sad it's a dark like emo yeah
you're too emo bro that's what I thought
it's your [ __ ] Aura dude did I talk
too much about the [ __ ] Great
Depression mommy with the beanie and a
trench coat they're probably like yo
this guy's way too dark well who is it
and I saw the commercial I'm like oh
okay I get it now what
I think because if I was gonna fulfill
the Asian role they didn't want a darker
Asian they were thinking more they want
ching chong yeah yeah so right before I
got fired I still had a meeting first
like I was in Ireland I remember they
sat me down right before getting on
stage and they're like and it was like
that yeah you need to cut your hair your
bangs like this go dye your hair in the
next uh like City we go to
so obviously you look more Asian and
then can you do this when you giggle are
they like can you do this when you get
going
[Music]
they're like yes
wow that was pretty good though that was
pretty good though
[ __ ] dude that sucks and it went like
that
[Music]
foreign